guess what I did tonight
I went on a date
we went to a concert
and guess how many children I have four
guess what I'm divorced
and now I'm a single mom
that means I take care of my children by myself
that has nothing to do with who I sleep with or things I do in my private time
I'm a single mom in that I singularly take care of all four of them children
and I still have a happy life
so this is just a reminder that you do not need to stay with somebody
just because you had children
with them you can leave
you can find happiness
and any man that tells you
someone isn't gonna love you because you have children
that's the kind of man that should have never become a father in the first place
and wanted nothing to do with children in the first place
because there are very normal men in this world
who understand children are a part of life
and now who cares
we're all about that age
that maybe kids are gonna be a deal
like part of the deal
so just make sure that you're happy